let's go next to LJ from Las Vegas LJ
what's going on in Vegas these days
um uh very close uh race with uh Adam
laxalt and uh basically the worst
Democratic uh you know candidate that
could ever exist but yes you know
we will be watching that one very
closely on Election night
yeah it's it's the sad fact that people
always like to complain about like you
know the pro the uh the candidates that
are available during the picture in the
general election while I'm screaming
here it's like that's why we have
primaries and why we should go vote
during primaries which is a more
important time indeed other than the
actual General but that's neither here
nor there what's on your mind today
I was actually wondering uh regarding
the the messaging that we have regarding
taxing and just like this you know uh
taxation is theft so you know I I used
to be a person of the Horizon uh I grew
up my entire life a person on the right
and as I've gotten older and I've got
access to more information and more
points of views yes I've learned you
know that there are some things that I
do uh believe I should stay conservative
on but when it comes to taxation I feel
like the the messaging that we have here
in the United States is all wrong right
and I've been watching Jon Stewart's uh
videos on it so if you have a chance or
really good we're talking still a lot
yes and so I think the messaging that we
have in the here the US is that you know
like when we're being taxed it's money
that's being taken away from us rather
than money that's being invested towards
us yeah right no that's for sure
and I I really do think that when you
have those conversations where I was
watching your debate coverage the other
day whereas uh I forgot I think it was
in Georgia with uh
God I can't remember the candidate that
was that well Georgia was Herschel
Walker and Rafael Warnock oh no Abrams
yes yes yes yes okay I had the
libertarian candidate on there yeah
and he kept screaming over and over
again it's like why don't you let the
American people decide why don't you let
the American people decide and I think
that messaging works because it's it's
saying a lie of course right but the
truth of the matter is is when they say
let the American people decide they say
well we want one person from one
Corporation to decide everything because
that's what benefits us most financially
right so when they say let the American
people decide and they say you know
what's it called Private Industry should
decide this because they're the ones who
can make the best decision yeah I feel
like they're saying no for removing the
option from the government who is voted
on by the American people it's like you
can't go up to your boss and tell them
it's like I want a thousand percent
raise
versus you know
um
being able to vote in primaries and
elections for someone who might give you
benefits for your
so LJ did you have a question today
I'm sorry my question is do you think
that is that the correct messaging so
like that was kind of like where I was
going for here is the messaging that
makes the most sense to me and I'm not a
focus group guy so this may not be
messaging that works but it's messaging
that makes sense to me and we go listen
all this talk about uh taxes or slavery
and all this different stuff you you
guys got to grow up okay if humans are
going to live in groups that need to
organize anything with more than 150
people sociology and anthropology and
group psychology tell us you need to
delegate certain decision making you
need to delegate certain powers you need
to centralize decision making and Powers
because otherwise you're basically
limited to groups of 150 people these
ideas that a million people in a city
are going to just kind of like naturally
organize in the way that these
Libertarians talk about it just does not
work there is no science that tells us
that that works in any discipline so
once you understand and concede that
what we need to do is to have a system
of voting that will make the elected
officials to whom we delegate power most
accurately representative of what the
voters want and part of this includes
that yes
we need to in a society
centralize the collection of taxes in
order to do big projects that just can't
be done by an individual or unilaterally
done by a couple of competing companies
who just sort of fight it out okay and
it's like we just got to be adults I I
can't think of any other way to explain
it
right
I completely agree because uh with my
libertarian couple libertarian friends
who are who still lean left they're not
like complete like idiots when it comes
to taxation yeah we all have the same
conversation point that we come back to
is like taxes are you know incorrectly
used like the war in Iraq sure
um cuts that are given to billionaires
who don't need it or to companies who
are doing extremely well still receive
tax cuts right
so or how the oil companies are you know
um in the corn and provided there's a
ton of examples of it but that's
generally my take on how I would talk
about uh taxes all right my friend I
gotta let you go okay
there's LJ from Vegas let's take a quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because we're going right back and we'll
hear from more people in just a moment